je t'avais qu'un homme et finalement il
était très généreux donc ça c'est un
trop mal passé
tout de suite avant ta blague tu es sûr
de ça non c'est bon ça va quand sinon
oui ça va ça se passe bien ça va j'ai
repris ma vie de femme célibataire donc
ah d'accord
je veux savoir quoi je suis choqué mais
les célibataire
bonjour madame
j'ai pas compris on va passer toutes les
missions à parler de Carla quoi
c'est ta première blague dans grosse
rigolade vas-y fais-toi plaisir et pense
que tu es libre fais-toi
roue libre alors ok c'est des anciens
agriculteurs et il y a Raymond et à
Ginette ils ont 80 ans ils ont réussi
leur vie tout va bien pour eux et là
Raymond il a envie de partir se promener
avec sa femme et de se balader dans la
propriété donc il regarde Ginette lui
dit bah voilà j'aimerais bien qu'on
aille promener je sais que bon tu te
fais vieille mais ça serait bien qu'on
profite qu'on regarde un petit peu ce
qu'on a accompli dans notre vie la
Ginette elle sait pas elle réfléchit à
quand même 80 ans elle se dit bon bah
allez Raymond ça nous rappellera de bons
souvenirs on y va on va dans les champs
et là il se pose il se balade et puis
d'un coup il tombe sur cette barrière il
dit tu sais Ginette cette barrière ça
nous rappelle quand même des bons
souvenirs à l'époque on se faisait
plaisir là-dessus la Ginette et le
regard et je sais vrai c'est plutôt pas
mal bon peut-être qu'on pourrait essayer
de recommencer ah quand même
80 ans je sais pas ça va marcher ou pas
bon bah allez on y va il coûte au pire
ça sera notre dernière fois ils avancent
ah c'est incroyable c'est magnifique
j'ai pas le souvenir qui a 30 ans de ça
tu me faisais aussi bien l'amour et là
regarde et puis il lui dit tu sais
avant la culture électrique ça
n'existait pas
ils viennent à peine d'être ensemble et
à sa femme elle va absolument faire
rencontrer ben du coup sa famille à son
chéri donc elle lui dit écoute je vais
organiser un repas il va avoir tout le
monde l'attente l'oncle mes parents la
grand-mère l'arrière-grand-mère le chien
et là bah là mais il est pas bien parce
qu'en fait il lui explique que quand il
a un rendez-vous il est stressé et quand
il est stressé mais il a des gaz il pète
il pète il pète du coup elle lui dit
écoute t'inquiète pas chérie je sais ton
problème mais j'ai vu avec le docteur on
va prendre une capsule et à chaque fois
t'inquiète pas pendant le repas tu
pourras prendre cette capsule il
t'arrivera rien t'inquiète pas 30
minutes avant tu auras plus rien ok ça
va je prends la capsule tout va bien il
arrive l'entrée il commence à parler
avec tout le monde ça se passe bien
arrive le plat et là comment ça avoir
mal au ventre il est pas bien il a les
sueurs et il lâche une caisse énorme oh
comment il va faire et tout l'arrière
grand-mère qui regarde le chat et dort
attention Médor OK
il continue le plat et continue le plat
l'entrée le dessert et là d'un coup il
continue
attention mais dehors attention là il se
dit bon ben c'est bon bingo l'arrière
grand-mère elle y voit rien elle pense
que c'est le chien je vais pouvoir me
lâcher et puis surtout j'arrive plus à
me retenir j'arrive plus à m'asseoir et
tout c'est très compliqué j'arrive à
tenir de discussion je lâche la dernière
caisse alors ça c'est la caisse de
l'année ça pète ça pète fort et là elle
a rien quand même regarde le chien lui
dit attention Médor je t'avais prévenu à
force il va te Chier dessus
alors cet argent il est dans la jungle
il passe de liane en liane il profite de
la vie qui et à un moment donné il passe
de liane en liane et puis bam il tombe
cher ses bras il perd ses jambes hyper
son sexe il y a plus rien qui va très
très grave accident et là il est
directement transféré à l'hôpital et le
docteur du coup quand il voit Tarzan il
se joue quand même c'est pas possible on
peut pas le laisser comme ça c'est quand
même Tarzan quoi c'est costaud écoute au
pire ben on va lui faire une trèfle de
bras et ben on va le remplacer ses bras
avec Ben des bras de singe comme ça au
moins il ira vite il passera de lianes
en liane puis ces gens qu'est ce qu'on
va faire et ben on va peut-être les
remplacer par des jambes de gazelle
comme ça il marchera très très vite il
va courir il va pouvoir galoper il va
être content mais par contre pour son
sexe et ben là je sais pas quoi faire
parce que quand même ça reste Tarzan je
peux pas je peux pas le rendre miskina
quoi donc il va falloir faire quelque
chose
bon ben à la place je sais que je vais
lui mettre une trompe d'éléphant le tour
est joué on passe à l'opération
Tarzan se réveille et là il se dit bah
voilà on a dû te transférer on a dû te
greffer certaines choses donc
rendez-vous dans 5 mois tu me diras
comment ça se passe OK Tarzan il est
content il retourne dans la jungle ça se
passe bien il retourne voir le docteur
et là il lui dit bon alors comment ça se
passe c'est nouveau bras avec écoute
c'est le docteur c'est le top vraiment
je passe de lien en lien j'ai beaucoup
de force c'est vraiment incroyable ah et
tes jambes alors ah ben alors là je
galope je cours très vite je rattrape
les guépards franchement merci beaucoup
docteur ah ok et bon et pour ton sexe
alors et ben par contre j'ai un vrai
problème avec mon sexe ah bon mais c'est
quoi ben malheureusement ma trompe elle
fait que donner à manger à mon trou du
cul
avec sa femme et dans leur couple ça va
plus du tout voilà sexuellement c'est
c'est horrible on se passe rien
et sa femme ben voilà elle dit écoute
mon mari j'ai besoin voilà que ça se
passe qui est quelque chose qui se passe
j'aimerais bien que j'accepte ma
proposition ah bon mais c'est quoi ta
proposition je comprends pas moi tu sais
je suis très religieux et tout qu'est-ce
qui se passe ben j'aimerais qu'il y ait
un bel étalon qui soit avec nous un
homme de 25 ans bien baraqué et tout
pendant qu'on fait l'amour ah bon mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il te fasse bah
j'ai pas de l'air de l'éventail ok bon
ça va bah monsieur ben Toussaint on y va
il commence il positionne le mec de 25
ans devant lui avec cet éventail lui dit
écoute je fais bien le jugement tu vends
du vent ma femme elle a envie d'être au
frais ok il y a pas de problème et tout
et commence par la toucher etc ça y va
et puis là elle lui dit écoute ça marche
vraiment pas mais je comprends pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je sais pas je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on switch ah bon
mais pourquoi qu'on switch parce que je
sais pas viens et je te dis le un de 25
ans prend la place de Monsieur
Bensoussan Bensoussan il prend
l'éventail il fait de l'air un courant
very passe il passe et là hurle
et là Monsieur ben tu sais il regarde le
mec il lui dit tu vois c'est pas si
compliqué de faire de l'air
c'est Monsieur Ben Soussan il est avec
sa femme on les retrouve et là sa femme
on peut plus tous les week-ends
franchement j'ai pas envie à mon âge
d'aller en boîte et tout non si si je te
laisse pas le choix on y va prends sa
veste son manteau il s'en va et là il y
a une queue de monstre une heure de
queue tu vois je te l'avais dit ça sert
à rien de venir et tout non sa femme
elle reste focus elle veut absolument
rentrer dans cette boîte de nuit et puis
là d'un coup le videur il appelle
monsieur ben tu sais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ne faites pas la queue venez
directement dans la boîte de nuit bon
alors sa femme elle commence à rechter
elle se dit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
oh il doit confondre écoute tu voulais
rentrer dans la boîte maintenant allez
on y va ok il y a pas de souci on rentre
dans la boîte là il est accueilli par le
serveur le serveur monsieur ben tout ça
je vous ai réservé le carré comme
d'habitude les bouteilles les fumigènes
monsieur ben tout ça dans la maison là
sa femme commence à se dire oh dis-moi
tu me prends pour une idiote c'est pas
possible tu fais quoi le weekend comme
je suis pas là mais non je te dis qu'il
doit confondre quelqu'un écoute
laisse-toi aller ok la gogo donc ça ça
arrive monsieur ben sous sang comme
d'habitude allez on y va là c'en est
trop pour sa femme elle prend son
manteau elle s'en va monsieur ben tout
ça il sait plus où donner de la tête la
gogo la les bouteilles sa femme qui
court il rattrape sa femme ils prennent
un taxi et là sa femme à lui hurle
dessus tu me prends pour une idiote tu
me manques depuis toutes ces années
finalement tu mets en boîte de nuit à
ton âge tu as pas honte et là le taxi il
se retourne et puis vous savez monsieur
Ben Soussan des [ __ ] on en a ramené
mais des comme elle jamais